Mark: Hello, everybody!  My name is Markiplier.
And welcome back to "Don't Starve Together!"
With Bob
Hi Bob!
Bob: Hi everybody!
Mark: Hi... uh.. so we are in a new world of Don't Starve!
And they've made a lot of changes. It's now in full release.
And, uh...
We get to go do stuff, apparently...
And so we're gonna--
Bob: Oo, soo..
Bob:  Show me where, when I go off screen for you
does it show you a little thing pointing at where I am?
Mark: Yeah it does!
Bob: Stop coming towards me
Mark: Ok...
Sorry...
I had to pick up seeds
Bob:  Oooohhhaa that's so helpful
I feel like when we played before it was like,
Alright now go
go... right
go straight right
and then I'm - NO no
I'm down from you or...
I - I feel like there was a lot of that situations.
Mark: There - there was OH MY GOD I CHOP SO FAST...
Mark: OH MY GOD
Mark: Also
Bob: You're gonna make the tree gods angry though.....
Mark:  I - I've discovered what the terrible secret is
Flashback Mark: The lumberjack has a lovely axe and a terrible secret.
Bob:  What's that?
Mark:  I'm not gonna tell ya
Bob:*giggles*
Mark:  Because I feel like it's better
Mark: I feel like it's better if we just leave this as it is
Mark:  But look at, look at this
Mark: YEH hYEH HYEH HYEH HYEH
Mark: Tree's gone, baby
Mark: Did you, uh, did you hear anything?
Bob: Did he just make, like, an orgasm sound after he chopped the tree down?
Mark: But do you, uh... can you... can you hear anyone talking to you?
Bob: No
Mark: OK, good, yeah, That's Good,  Yeah Yeh Uh Nobody's Nothing's Talking To Me Either
*Bob and Mark laugh*
Bob: Well, as long as we're in the same uhh - on the same page we're fine
Mark: Hell Yeah Man!
Bob: It's... really already going to be nighttime?
It's really already gonna be like that?
Mark: Apparently, Good God.
Oh no, It's just evening
We're fine on evening.
Mark: But we do need to make a campfire.                 Bob: Oh right there's the clock
Bob: Oh right there's the clock
Bob: Yeah. Well, we need stones for that, right?
Mark: WAIT, why-
Bob: Are we still looking to just make a regular campfire
Mark: Yeah. Uh... I got bad news. Um...
Mark: Apparently
Bob: What's that?
Mark: My wood meter is going Down.
Bob: You're at your sad when you destroy wood.
I- no. Just. I don't know what the wood meter is.
It's just a meter of wood, and it's goin' down.
Bob: Can you- can you, eat wood?
Mark: I don't know if I could eat- if I could eat wood.  Bob: Do you need me to do something to your wood?
Mark: OH MY GOD I CAN EAT WOOD!!
HOLY shit!
*Bob laughs*
Mark: I.. I, I literall- I eat wood.
Bob: Ey, there's bees over here, let's not do that.
Mark: I- I eat wood?!
What does that mean?!
Bob: Whatever you gotta do, man.
Mark: I just. Okay.                                                              Bob: I'm not- I'm not here to judge.
Mark: Th- the meter goes down when I chop wood...
but it goes back up when I eat wood. So it's kinda like a-
I chop faster but also I'm- I have to eat some of this. I'm sorry.
It's just.. It's the way life goes.
Bob: S'all good. S'all good in the wood.
Mark: But the wood definitely, doesn't raise my hunger.
That's, that's one thing wood doesn't do..
Bob: Well that's useful...
Mark: All of this horrifically unuseful.
Bob: Stuff you need to eat that does not make you less hungry.
Mark: Yeah, exactly. Isn't this great...
Bob: Perfect.
Mark: Heh, just my... Oh, and also my secret is, my axe is talking to me.
Bob: Wow, really?
Mark: My axe is encouraging me to kill... *Bob laughs* but not people, just trees.
Bob: Kill the trees!
Mark: Kill the trees!
The trees are your mortal enemy!
Bob: Well, but it's in- it's in "Don't Starve" talking right? So it's like,
Wah wah bwah ba wah wah wah.
Mark: Wah wah wah wahhh...
I gotta blow dart.
And ima blow..
Ima blow that bir- GODDAMNIT THE BIRD I was gonna- Wait. Don't move. Ima
Bob: Oh, hey. Hey, I- I know where we should set up camp.
Mark: Ughh...
Bob: It's right here.
I see bushes, I see rabbit holes...
Mark: Nice!
Bob: We should set up camp and I should craft some traps.
Mark: Hell yeah!
Bob: So we can start, uh, doin' that shit.                      Mark: Oh hell yeah!
Mark: Okay so...We need-  Bob: Oh. Hell yeah.
Mark: We need some grass to be able to make a camp fire.
Bob: I need also some grass.
Mark: Ok, don't worry I'll... heh...
My- heh. I reequipped my axe and its like, " You came back for me!" Hah, "So sweet!"
Bob: There's a piggity-goo over here.
Mark: A piggity-goo?
Bob: There's a bunch of pig heads on a... Oh, there's a touch stone.
What do those do?
Mark: A to- I don't know, touch it.
That's probably a good thing. Touch it!
Bob: I.. No.. I'm gonna wait. I think we should wait until we at least have a little bit of, uh...
of serenity and success before we go touchin' things.
Mark: Come on man, touch it.                                         Bob: Aw fuck...
there's a thing! There's a thing burrowing around over here.
Mark: Burrowing?                                                               Bob: Making like, groundhog tunnels.
Mark: Oh...
Bob: I think we should stay in the yellow part. I think that's our thing. I think the yellow part...
Mark: There's plenty of berry bushes, there's burrows. We got a lot of resources here. It's a good starting point.
So that people won't be...                                                 Bob: It's the place to be man.
Mark: Yeah, people won't be incredibly maaaaad at us when we eventually faillll.
Oh it's night!
Bob: Oh shit!
Please make the fire.
Mark: I'm gonna make a fire! I'm gonna make a fire!
Ohh, why am I not making a fire?
Riiiiiiiiiigghhhtttttt... There!
Bob: Hey-ey-ey. He-Hey!
Mark: Perfect timing huh?
Bob: Welcome to the hi.
Mark: Yeah, hi. How's it going?
I uh- Sorry about killing your twin sister, apparently.
Bob: S'all good. S'all good.
Mark: Heh, is it? It's all go- Oh wow, you're very forgiving. eh-I- I appreciate that a lot.
Bob: It's fine. It's fine.
Uhh. How do you make a torch?
Mark: Uhm, you need...
Bob: Oh, I can make a torch.
Mark: Yeah, I can make a torch. Yeah also...
Bob: I'm gonna go set some. Rabbity-trapities.
Mark: Okay you do that.
Also, good news. Uhh... I, never run out of axe. My axe is, uh, unbreakable.
Bob: Oh wow, really?
Mark: Yeah!
Bob: That's really nice.
Mark: My axe just told me to chop some trees.
I gotta go dude. I gotta go.
I gotta go.
(growling voice) I gotta chop some trees, man.
Bob: Uhh.
Bob: You feelin' okay man?
Mark: YEAHIMFINEWHATAREYOUDOIWHATSWRONGWITHYOU?
Bob: I'm- I'm- I'm fine y'know I'm just- Just, you know
Fine.
Mark: *Mumbling*
*sniff*
Mark: Phew, anyway...
Bob: God! Just! Set the trap where I told you to-
Girl.
*Mark snickers* Lady.
Person.
Mark: Giirrlll.
Bob: Giirrrll. Why you fuckin'- why you fuckin' my shit up?
Mark: Let's see. Maybe we need to calm- what? Calm down?
Uh-oh.
What's happening to me?
I'm gonna see what happens when my- my wood meter goes low.       Bob: Are you about to go
into a wood-icidal rage?
Mark: Yeah, my-my-my axe is starting to get worried.
"You might want to eat a log." It just told me that, and I'm like, 'Why, that doesn't seem like a logical thing to do.'
"Slow down, I'm worried about you."
What is happening to my guy? *Bob laughs*
My axe is worried about me.
Bob: I don't wanna die. But I wanna be near you to witness what happening.
Mark: Yeah okay. It's only gonna be a few more trees. Trust me.
Mark: Oooah!
Mark: I'm a Were-Bea *heh* ve *her* *her* *her*
Mark: AAAAUUUHH
Mark: Fuck you tree!
Bob: Holy. Fucking. Shit.
Mark: AAAAOOOAGGHH
Mark: C'mere you Beaver Bitch!
Mark: EEEeegh
I can eat
Aw I can eat
Both: Oh my god
Bob: Eat all of that
Both: Oh Yes
Mark: My hunger meter got replaced
That's Amaaazing!
This is Amazing!
Is this permanent?
Bob: I fuckin' hope not, you drop your axe!
I've got like, hillbilly music in the background
*Bob laughs*
Bob: No, don't eat him! Noooo
Markiplier: Oooooh, we're okay.
Bob: Oh, you dug him up
Mark: You're welcome
Bob: You dug him up!
Bob: Good shit! Good shit, good shit.
You're welcome
Pick up Lucy the axe. I wonder if you pick up Lucy
If you like--
BOB: I couldn't, I couldn't
MARK: No?
BOB: I walked over there, there was no option to do anything.
MARK: Your character was just like, "I know better than this, this is horrifying!"
Ok I took a hit to my sanity but when I was eating as a beaver it did fill up my hunger
BOB: well that's good
MARK: Or did it, maybe it didn't
MARK: Maybe I ate some stuff
BOB: I captured a bunny-bunny
Mark: Did-a-did ya? Bob: Almost captured another bunny-bunny.
Mark: Good I'mma-we're gonna get more food here, we're gonna build a nice base here
Then we're gonna be good! Right?
OH WOW Birch trees they give birch nuts!
And you can eat them.
Bob: Oh..
Mark: Oh that's handy!
Bob: Do you just like shake them?
Mark: Uhhhh I don't know I've-I've only tri...I've only tried chopping them
Mark: Can you....(Bob laughs) Can you shake them?
Bob: (mocking voice)Well I don't know uhh I've only tried chopping them.
Mark: I literally-I-I only know how to chop I mean...
If you, if you need someone to chop it I've got your back but...shake? What? (Bob laughs)
Bob: Just...just..you know it's just my, it's my world view it's what I do I-I
Dunno how to-how to, how else to be.
Mark: Ugh, di-my dad chopped uhh I chop.
My mom was on the show "Chopped", I mean uh
I can't do nothing but chopped.
Bob: I feel like...I feel like those are linguistically related but not actually related
Mark: Ok, It's a joke
Alright?
Bob: Na-I-but I you can't...(sighs)
Mark: I'm gonna touch this touchstone.
Bob: (Holding back laughter) Oh good ok.
I was wondering how soon it would be before we lost.
Mark: Oh no apparently it doesn't-you can't touch it, it won't let you touch it
Bob: I really want some like gold, that's what I want.
There is...
Mark: Well, yeah...
Ooh!
There's something in your trap here I'mma...reset your trap.
Bob: I am super-de-duper hungry we should cook up some of these there rabbits that I got and eat them up.
Eat-em-up and stuff :V
Mark: Set the dang trap.
There we go, ok!
Where was camp?
Bob: Uhhh, anywhere on this yellow part I'm coming back towards you. It's over to the left of, I picked up the ashes it was like right here.
Mark: Ummm if we had more stone I could make a more permanent one but, for now this will do.
Habooski!
And then Imma cook-imma murder this rabbit.
Bob: So....plant...that guy...yeah it's our sapling now.
Mark:Yeah, ok Imma cook these birchnuts
Bob: Can you move like to the side of the fire?
Mark: NO I'M COOKING YOU DINNER
You will let me cook
Bob: I also have rabbit morsels that I need to cook.
I'mma give you all of my birchnuts.
Bob: Ohhh gimme your nuts!
Mark: Yeah take my nuts! God take those nuts!!
Bob: Oh! gimme your, OHH GOD
Mark: You like those nuts?
Bob: Imma give you some of my meat.
Mark: Thanks man
Bob: Imma feed you my meat(Mark moans as he eats it) OHMY GAWD OHHH! YES!!
Mark: RIGHT IN MY MOUTH! AHHHH!!
ONMNOMNOMNOM!
Bob: How do you like my meat?
Mark: Almost as good as these logs!
Anyway you didn't see but I ate a log.
Bob: I...yeah you made a crunchy-crunch
Mark: BLOW! AHAHAHA! Got him!
Bob: (Laughs)
Mark: Yeah!
Bob: That is so satisfying! Hehehehe!
Mark: Hell yeah!
Bob: Blow! Hahahahaha!
(Much laughter)
Got em!
Mark: Don't make fun of me.
Bob: AHAHAHA!
Ok
Mark: (Obnoxious creepy laughter)
Put some longs in this fire...
Bob: I'm out of-I'm out of...
Grassy-Grass
Mark: We got grass already.
Alright, well...
Let's see.
We got.. A lot of time till' actual night, so you can go and do stuff
Bob: Yeah Imma' go and-
Bob: Get some more grass. Mark: I'm gonna go... South-ish
Bob: Set some more traps. Mark: See if I can find some more stone down there.
Bob: We need to find uh....
Rocks... Gold...
Mark: You're correct-oh it's so the south!
Nope no rocks it's just the rockier-yeah it's south.
Okay, definitely south. Bob: Well there-
Bob: There was noting north, so.. that's good.
Mark: Okay so I found a gold vein.
Mark: Mine this one.. Bob: Oh yes-oh but you don't have a pickaxe
Mark: I just made one cause I'm a pro at this game.
We've been playing this long enough that I know exactly what I'm doing.
Mark: Okay.. Bob: Yeah
Mark: There's just gold lying on the ground here.
Why is there gold just lying on the ground?
By the way I'm in a graveyard,
But there's gold lying on the ground.
Bob: Well you should definitely take the gold lying-
Mark: I've been taking it non-stop. Bob: -lying on the ground in the graveyard-yeah
Bob: No-No question-
Mark: Hell yeah. Bob: -absolutely take that shit.
Mark: It's like free money, why wouldn't I?
Jeez
What am I, stupid? No! I'm taking it!
*Bob laughs*
Bob: What am I, an imbecile?
*Mark laughs* Bob: No!
Thanks for agreeing with me man.. I'm definitely.. Uh.. A smart man.
Bob: You are the smartest.
Mark: Okay I've got seven gold so far
and I'm gonna come back now cause it's about to turn night.
Bob: So how do I make a Sciency-goo?
We only need one gold! And some logs
Did you get any rocks?
Mark: Oh hell yeah!
You know I got rocks
Bob: Oh I know you got the rocks, bro.
Mark: You know I always got rocks from my main bro
Bob: I know you got the rocks
Mark: Man, I got the best rocks
You ask anyone around town who's got the best rocks?
MMMEEEEE!
Bob: Markiplier. Markiplier
Mark: yeah that guy, they don't say me..cause that would......
Mark:  that wouldn't  be me
Bob: who has he best rocks?
-Meeeeee
Mark: Wait no
Mark Dude!
Bob: No
No I'm like who else has the best rocks?
Me!
My rocks!
My man rock's good!
Ugh.
Goddamn, I suck at placing these traps.
Oh, my god, there's so many...
So many...
Berry bushes.
There's like 5 berry bushes right here.
just trap
If you could just go over the hole? Thank you
Mark: Holy shit. I've got tones and tones of berries       Bob: Ok, It's going to be bed time
I'm comming back. Did I.. Is there fuel any left in the thing...
I.. I did... no idea...    Bob: I don't know, I'm not there
I'm not there eather
I don't see your icon on the minimap     Bob: Demon! Show yourself!
It's barely there. It's... It's almost not there but It's a little bit there
I'm coming back
I see ya
Hello!
Whoosh Whoosh Whoosh Whoosh
Oh that's a fire,
Thats some sweet fire
I've got.... I'm gonna put this on the ground
uhh oh
That's smolderen, That's ohh  ohh
Oh god
ohhhhh
OHHHHHH NOOO!
OHHHHHHH NOOOOOO OHHHHHHH
Oh..... Hello
Ohh is this how we trade?
Okay you....
I don't know its like, the creepyist song ever
Here you can take my berrys
Cause I've got a good store of em
Bob: I'm going to pick up these god nuggets
Mark: You do that. Bob: And I'm going to make us
Bob: Oh Actually, do you have logs & rocks?
Mark: Yup.
Bob: I also need logs.
Logs, Logs. Heh, do I got logs? Heh, Whatcha talkin' about? What do you think I ate them all?
Bob: So do we want, do we want a permanently science it up here?
Mark: Hell yeah. This is a good location, down south of the rock. Up north of more stuff.
Bob: Hell yeah. Science machine mother fucker.
Mark: And we can continue this in the next episode.
Bob: Mother Fuc-ker
Mark: I shouldn't have started eating sour patch, this is a bad time for this.
(Bob Laughs)
Mark: So Thank you everybody so much for watching. We're gonna play a few more episodes of Don't Starve™️ and this time we're gonna do actually good because we know what we're doing and we're not gonna fail.
We've never been actually been able to play this game right in the entire time we've played this, so.
Bob: Hehe, I thought you were gonna say we never actually failed. (Bob Laughs)
Mark: Oohh god no, we've failed too many times, but-
Bob: Nah, We're supper good.
Mark: But thank you guys, everybody, so much for watching and as always, we'll see you in the next video! BYE BYE!